uh modeling extreme events with pymc so
this will be uh an a talk where I used
uh PMC to to basically study a very
explicit example um extreme rainfall in
New York actually so bit of an intro um
last couple of years uh we have seen
many extreme rther events this year we
had temperature records in Texas uh we
had last year historic routs fles floods
in New York City the one I will be
focusing on uh like two years ago and
this list goes on and on um but what I
found interesting is when such extreme
things happen like they say oh it's the
worst rainfall since so many years like
how can we think as a data science think
about that not just look in the table
and see like oh all right have 50 years
of data this is the first time this
happened but how can we quantify that
and uh yeah make maybe make some
predictions out of that um so here's the
outline um so first off uh statistics of
extremes uh it sounds maybe a bit boring
but I promise it's actually uh quite
interesting but I will keep it short um
just so that we can focus on the
takeaway um then quick intro to basan
modeling with PMC uh it would be helpful
if you already have some experience with
with basing re reasoning and we had some
Sprint session about that as well but
this will be very quick uh recap in case
you're not uh super familiar with it
then the the the example that's the
extreme rainfall in uh New York modeled
with PMC so that will be the bulk of the
talk and then a bit as a bonus slightly
more complex uh example where I'm going
to use gaing processes um earlier this
conference I think on day one we already
had a great talk about gaing processes
so I'm not going to redo that I'm just
going to apply it um and so let's take
it from
here statistics of extreme events um so
this is the brief uh
introduction in the background you
actually see an extreme event this
happened in the Netherlands in 53 when
there was a water flop and actually that
sparked a lot of interest in how you can
uh think about that I'm not going to
talk about that particular event so as I
said I'm going to talk about the the
rainfall New York
so that actually happened like two years
ago uh picture on the right you see CS
cars uh basically floating in on the
highway and then um so after after that
happened it was clear that there was a
new record of rainfall that fell in a
single day so there was 8.4 Ines um and
then you could so that was the highest
on record and then how extreme is that
um so natural question was what was the
previous record uh so let's look at that
that was like 54 44 years ago of 6.7
inches so that's significantly lower so
this what happened in September was
indeed extreme and and we see here
basically just a plot of all the the
daily rainfall so the question then is
like how extreme is this or actually um
maybe a better way to ask
better question to ask is like given a
certain level level what I mean is like
say four in so how many years H do we
expect it to happen so is that maybe
every 10 years and then I can ask
similar question like uh six uh inches
so how often do we expect that to happen
and then well maybe that's every 40
years and so on um naive way to approach
it is just look at all all the available
data and just count how often such
things happen but for the extremes
that's not going to be very precise
because uh the 8.4 inches happens only
once but in we happen to have just 50
years of data but it doesn't doesn't
really mean it happens only every 50
years so um the more precise way to do
that is if you can somehow fit uh
probability distribution and use that to
answer questions like how of how often
something happens so then the question
is which distribution to fit so that's
where extreme value Theory uh will come
into
play so I'm going to look at the same
data again as we had in the previous
slides so I'm looking on the left but
what I've done here is I highlighted per
year the Maxima so each year I only take
the maxima and the rest of so I have
basically one day a year and the rest of
the data I'm going to throw away
um so it's bit radical but it will be
clear why we're doing that so in general
um for natural phenomena like rainfall
temperature data Etc if you look at
Daily data that is a complex
distribution which we which we don't
know but if we follow this methodology
only taking the uh annual annual
Maxima we get the data look something
like this and here we can actually
describe it with some called Extreme
value distribution um so there's
actually a theory um that states under
which conditions um you can fit that
distribution and this distribution will
look something like this um and this I
want to emphasize here although I'm
focusing on rainfall data this is a very
uh general statement um so this has been
applied successfully not only to
rainfall temperature stock market
crashes if you are working trying to
predict server loads Mac Peaks uh you
can all if you focus on the extremes
fits typically successfully uh this
distribution um so this distribution has
three
parameters um the interpretation doesn't
really matter too much but you can think
of them like a location scale and the
shape how how tail uh something is so
the higher XI the more extreme things uh
we can have
expect
so this uh distribution function we're
going to use um in PMC but before we're
going to do that uh as promised quick
intro into uh basan modeling with
PMC so let's let's contrast that with a
non basan method so if we take any
machine learning problem we typically
want to minimize some uh loss function
via gradient s so artist impression here
on the right so we try to find this
Global minimum here and maybe we have
taken this path um typically this a very
fast uh approach but two things that are
hard with this approach is we may find
this um this minimum but we have no good
way to quantify how certain we are with
our estimate uh so think about uh how
would you go about constructing your
confidence interval for instance or if
you have some prior information whatever
that may be um it's typically not very
easy to incorporate that in your
standard um non basan uh
framework so let's then look at the Bas
framework so super quick intro um so the
basan framework all as the name uh
suggest focuses on
base rule which we have here in the
middle of the screen and what we are
interested in is basically on the left
the so-called posterior distribution of
model parameters Theta so model
parameters Theta we after given some
data act and we can compute that using
base rule so this one here is which is
what we call our likely Hood function so
that's basically given some Theta how
you're what distribution your uh data
will follow and we have a prior
distribution so why is this useful um
well a the uncertainty now for
parameters is captured via this
distribution so another artist
impression on the right so we have say
if Theta is two dimensional uh it may
look something like this so some complex
uh distribution but the width of that
Peak will tell you like yeah how certain
are you right so we can um so the
equivalent in maybe non-basic methods we
just to find only this maximum in this
case here in the basan method we
interested in the entire distribution so
we want to capture the whole
thing um and so that's going to be a bit
more work actually and we'll we'll we
going to leverage PMC uh to do exactly
that then the other thing is uh if we
focus on base rule um there is this P of
theta here which is our prior
information we have um and in our
example we'll look at two examples the
first case we don't really have a good
way to specify this so we make it
uninformative but then the second
example the gaan processes this one will
actually be become very
important um so I'm not going to go into
the details of uh how you actually
sample from a distribution um that's
that's too technical for for the scope
of this talk but um that's the purpose
of
PMC so quick recap of what PMC is it's
an open source library for uh
probalistic programming in Python um as
we will see in with some code Snippets
it's a very intuitive way to code up uh
basan models um it has an effective
Monto Carlo uh market chain sampling and
it has lots of uh built-in tools uh to
inspect your distributions so it's it
basically um comes with batteries
included and the PMC Community is great
um if you have uh questions um you get
get get typically answers real quick so
um yeah as even as beginners I think
this is great uh to start to play around
with um all right so we captured now
very quick introduction on Extreme value
Theory very uh quick introduction on B
modeling and PMC so let's put these
together so back to the rainfall in New
York
City um so what we're going to do here
is we're going to fit a distribution uh
based on the rainfall
data so this is the entire uh PMC
program I use except for loading the
data C and I think what's also missing
is an import pmcs PM um but this is
basically it so the first line is you
basically Define what your model is and
then we will step through it so here I
def defined prior distribution so um in
case of the extreme value distribution
there were three parameters so I defined
distribution for each of them um and
these exact values that is more like
experience in question what they should
be um but not super relevant for um this
talk um however how I uh figure those
out but the important thing is it's very
clean code so you just have basically
one line to Define what the prior
distribution is um and I'm yeah then the
next thing is the likelihood function so
this is Extreme value Theory
distribution which we discussed uh a few
slides back and what you can see here it
depends on these distributions so this
mu Sigma Andi here are you can think of
them as uh not as a parameter but really
as a probability distribution each so
they will fit into this likelihood and
then Z here is our data so this is the
the the basically the rainfall data and
to be more precise this is once we took
the annual Maxima so in our case this is
like uh 50 data points so that that's
not an awful lot um and then uh once you
set up the model uh you need to sample
from it so that's this line uh and so
this in this case takes maybe a few
minutes uh to get sufficient
samples um and then what we after is the
posterior distribution for these
parameters so this is a
three-dimensional uh distribution so
that somewhat hard officialize but I
plotted
basically um when I average out the
other two so I have for each of them uh
the distribution and as you can see so
me that's around
2.8 but um it varies roughly between 2.6
and and and and three so that tells you
like since we had limited data we don't
really have a very precise estimate of
what mu is but we by looking at the
entire distribution we basically know uh
the
uncertainty similar for the other two um
so yeah this is probably the most
important slide of this talk um
basically to emphasize like I we we'll
go to the results in a second but um
yeah starting with base rule a prior a
likelihood and a posterior only few
lines of code and then um
yeah you fit the the model and then it's
afterwards straightforward to compute
any analytics um you care about so
that's the we're going to do
next so one step back so as I mentioned
earlier so when we want to discuss about
how some how extreme something is we
going to look at return levels given a
return period so what I mean by that is
say every every 100 years we expect to
observe something like um well just
let's look at this graph say like eight
and a half inches or
more or if I look at say The Other
Extreme like 20 years so every 20 years
we expect
something um of six inches or more so
mathematically that's just this uh
function so we say the return level um
and then This Is What You observe so
something bigger than a given return
level and then the probability is
basically one of the the period so the
40 years 60 years and so on um and what
we want to do now is actually um I'm not
going to do the algebra but invert it
write this as a function of the return
period and then get the return level out
so that we can construct this
graph um and that's what I did uh with
PMC so this is a few other lines of code
um so let's St step through those so
again we specify what our model is um
here I add some data which is a return
period so that's a whole bunch of values
ranging from 10 to uh 100 years and then
here I basically um computed return
level based on the return period uh as a
function of these parameters which
again are distributions so hence the
output of this is also a distribution
for each of the return periods so how
you can think about it is the the thick
blue line is basically for each return
period is the mean of that distribution
and that width is basically the
uncertainty um so we can read off um
for example in hand so for when we
observed the 8.4 inches that actually
corresponds to an event we expect to
happen every 83 years so that's relative
extreme but as I mentioned before
there's quite some uncertainty here but
again this is the the beauty I would say
of the basian approach is that there was
no extra work needed to get these um
uncertainties um we get that pretty much
for free because we're working with um
distributions all the way if you were to
do nonbasic method you have to do more
work um to to figure that
out all right so this is the main
example
um so let's switch gears and make a look
at a slightly more complex example so
we're going to go um slightly faster to
this U but this is more to
Showcase um yeah what PMC is capable of
and just to um showcase yet another
Technique we have about 10 minutes just
want to give you a heads up thank
you um so the gausian process prior so
uh I will keep it uh
brief so going back to the previous
model so how can we um make it better um
so one naive uh suggestion is like add
longer history go further back in time
well a that data may not necessarily be
available and B they may not be
appropriate especially since we we know
the climate is changing um looking what
happened like 150 years ago is probably
not super relevant for what's happening
right now so instead of adding more time
we can do something else and we can make
it a spatial problem so um if I look at
the map here so the Red Dot is what we
have been focusing on so data for a
single weather station but what I can do
instead is look at all these stations
and basically use their data as well to
make better uh prediction for this
single
station and we can do way more with that
as well which which I will show as well
but for now the focus is how can we use
more stations to make a better
prediction for this single red station
so the answer to that is um a gaan
process and to be more precise to use
that as a prior which I um eluded at the
beginning of the talk one great
advantage of a basan approach is that
you can use prior information and here
prior information is going to be uh in
basically observation from other weather
stations so super quick um intro about
gausian processes um as I mentioned
there's already been a great talk about
explaining it in detail um so I'm not
going to do that I'm just gonna tell you
what it is so instead of basically say
if we have the 10 stations have 10
individual uh prior distribution with
par parameters mu1 two three and so on
corresponding to each of of the stations
we're going to say well we make mu we
make that the function of X where X is
the location of the different stations
um but me so this is the probably the
difficult part of what the guys
processes mu
follows uh a probability distribution so
we what we basically doing is we samping
now functions um and that is uh somewhat
Illustrated here on the right so each of
these lines is a function and we sampled
that from a gausian process
distribution and what you will see so
the crosses those are observations at
locations X1 X2 X3 that these lines tend
to go uh through through my observations
act or at least close to it uh but the
further away I I'm from my observations
I'm less certain and then as you can see
it fans out here um but um if I in this
case I have say a few observations next
to each other that help you figure out
what this function should be um and
that's how
basically um via the the gaan process
prior we can actually uh uh learn uh
have to different stations learn from
each other so how does that look in PMC
slightly more complicated but the
structure is still the same um so this
is just specifying where the stations
are some constant data some hyper
parameters not super relevant um and
then these are my um PRI distributions
which I had before so have one for Mu
Sigma Andi and now I'm basically
specifying that they depend on a gaan
process which depends on the
the on the coordinates for each of the
stations so it's maybe not super obvious
from this this slide but this is now uh
a model for my 10 uh station
simultaneously um but we have the same
structure so we have our three priors
which are now functions and then we have
a likelihood as before and as you can as
you can see the notation suggest that we
now have the many uh stations um so
again we can sample from this uh like
before um nothing really changes and
then we can evaluate this um so I did
that again for the same station so um
let's say set
like again we going to look at for now
only at the prediction for this single
station um so the blue is what we had
before and now we have the orange uh so
it's slightly lower but what's more
important actually that the uncertainty
of the the orange fit is now only half
of what we had before so going back to
the to
the example of hurricane Ida uh what
initially our estimation was it was once
in8 threeyear event now it's actually a
once in a 100e event now we incorporated
uh information of nearby stations but
the as I said the uncertainty is only
half so we are more uh yeah we have
better predictions uh This Way um there
is no need to focus only at one station
so this is slightly different uh well
different code um but same ideas as
before so I ran this with uh uh 3500
stations actually in the in the United
States um I haven't depicted the various
uh locations but there it is somewhat
spread out um but with the gausian
process prior I can also make
predictions for um points where I have
no data so I can make this grid as fine
as I want and um yeah as you can see
here you can see the here there's a lot
of rainfall in this um this area of the
states here is uh less because there's a
mountain rate here and so on but this is
just to illustrate that um yeah you can
make predictions for uh locations where
you have no actual observations as long
as you have um somewhat nearby
observations um you should be able to
make uh precise enough
um uh predictions all right so that was
the slightly more complicated example
um the takeaways oh sorry real quick
just wanted to give you a four minute
warnings and we have a couple questions
in chat so okay perfect so very quick to
take takeaways if you think about
modeling extreme events doesn't have to
be we think about extreme value theory
if you want to do some basing modeling
in Python I would consider PMC if you're
working with spatial problems consider a
gusan process so uh that was uh the talk
thanks for attending happy to take any
questions you y that was great I think
we've uh got a couple questions in chat
so I can go ahead and read them off for
you um let's see first and foremost PMX
equals equals pimcore experimental isn't
that Target accept value of 098 a bit
High what is your R hat
rhat yeah so uh I like the very
technical detailed question um yeah so
um since this is a very heavy tilt
distribution uh the extreme value I had
to uh increase basically the the target
uh ratio the r hat they are um I don't
know on top of my hat I'm happy to come
back to you um we look it up and share
that but I I check those in their
they're they're in the expected
range and um we had a request for slides
is there a place that we can um view
these
slides uh perfect yeah I mean uh I will
basically add haven't done it yet but I
will today add the slides to the GitHub
um so there's a notebook that actually
works through the entire thing we
uh discuss today and we'll add the these
slides as well and I will probably also
post it on
Discord yeah that would be
fantastic I'm just going to um include
the link that you shared on your screen
in
chat there we
go
um yeah another request to to get slides
on Discord let's
see got another question instead of
using latitude and longitude for X can
we instead use the range from the newer
station to the surrounding
stations
um
well not really um because um although
in my talk I I focused on like um this
one particular station but when I code
it up um I do them all together uh so I
need to have the difference uh the
distance between all the different
stations not only between nework and the
other
stations and last question we have time
for from Christopher put on stage when
do we need gsh in process and when does
that have more value over nonlinear leas
Square uh well so the gaan process here
is that I as I mentioned I can use it as
a prior so think about as sampling over
functions um so yeah I don't think there
is a an easy equivalent uh for a non-
basan way
in but yeah I mean the Gan process is
very wide subject I have only scratched
tip of the I Iceberg and focusing on a
very spec specific uh application